you should absolutely start flirting  with broader content 100  it needs to be part of your mix the  first 50 pieces of business content i  made every comment was [ __ ] you stay in  your lane wine boy  the [ __ ] do you know about business i'm  like jesus christ i was like that's all  i've been doing i just became wine guy  to you because of youtube i'm like i am  business you need to be  insane insane about facebook fan page  output number one the game is back at  scale youtube shorts number two tick  tock number three  you must dominate those three arbitrages  how many pieces of content like a day  would you say ideal for per platform and  then there's twitter and instagram and  regular youtube and link and linkedin